Andthere
And there
is a danger not
and I always
Andthere
and I want to see sun and face
sanderlan Good afternoon everyone,
the commitment with which
this social summit closed
and for the first time in  history of the European
Union it was possible to sign such a
comprehensive commitment so vicious
involving all the social partners
200 european parliament the president of
the european commission and group to sign
while the fi trion is now
deposited in the hands of the board so that
the board can give continuity and this
it is a very important commitment that is
a commitment and there are Europeans and the
social partners who are committed to
implementing the action plan
and to putting into practice the social pillar of the
European course of social rights
and in 2017 we had managed to approve
20 general principles now  we have an
action plan to take
concrete measures that can bring these
general principles to the
day-to-day lives of citizens  this
port summit is not the arrival point movement
but it is a point of relaunch of
this action plan moment in which, in
addition to what the commission proposed,
a broad agreement was obtained from all
partials for this action plan to
be carried out This is  a plantation like
any other is an action plan that
has quantified goals in terms of
employment in terms of training in
terms of combating
poverty  For him, the semester will no longer be
just an exercise in assessing
macroeconomic imbalances looking
at crime looking at the deficit looking at the
debt but will also look at
reducing poverty for meeting
training targets for creating
new jobs and Pillar  social comes at a
very important moment in which
the cop-19 has reminded us all of what
is a distinctive mark of Europe its
social model
a long time ago  year in which we all discover a
value of their fundamental age,
understanding that each one is only
protected when we are all
protected and that is why
this social Europe and ambition of
social Europe takes on a new meaning, certainly because of this in the
special eurobarometer that was published
at the end of 2020  nine out of ten
Europeans said they wanted to move forward in
social Europe that's what the instructions What
did the mission do to present the
plan that's what the Portuguese presence did
in promoting this summit that's what the
European Parliament did or sign with the
commission and the  social partners this
commitment which is why we can
leave here with the hope that we can
now have the bases for an
economic recovery that
is based on the Double climate and
digital transition but that is also a
Just transition and this is also one reason
why this  Pilar deaf
particularly important moment because the
climatic and digital transmissions
also include enormous losses.  sharp from the social point of
view of employment the need
to deform replication
professional retraining transition
from employment to another opportunity to
create more and better jobs and
so we can tell Europeans that this
transition will be a
digital and fair green direction
I want  while the rotating Presidency
of the Union would like to thank the social partners
for the great impact they have had in building
this commitment is to win the
European Parliament the mobilization of all its
efforts and the contribution of its report
to this please also thank
those committed to the economic and
social committee and  to the Committee of the Regions and very
especially to thank the
joint work commission that we made and a
retive of being glass and would have from this
summit with the president of the Commission
Úrsula founded in Thank you so much
I thank you very much Antônio thank you
very mate of life ah f  ***se Berry
strong Mary Sweet Will of Health to
witness it I love you by da  y and I must
say you really want One Direction in his
work with it go and it would not work
with the first so sweet And principles
and friend but now with Bears reader
can verify if time or left
Partners we represent attending the
commitments and join the  commitments
side by old friend stakeholders added
Hot today so it is not only about
principles Worten padre and if think
is  calling it the name of the
division can unit to people but are also
protects
And why is it that if he was
anime pro magnet great risks of Life we
lived endure pandemic of course we are
young we were difficult time and with
the level of difficulty  are much how the
negative Impact of dependent on the
roads we hope you remind me of
vaccination campaign during the first
year of High dilution sing too
Dreamer kind of the first shot was da
Twitter havin  g to Protect his Life and
various livelihoods for example bike
racing do show instrument to make should
please stay
Us informed  -fi sim
so far but now I can't see the second
shot Waze Face Clean download his family
And his friend by Next Generation kill
you all investment made repeat Words
ending with the building and Skills at
Antônio with clip each of the station
and the  European Dream but from can to
get to know All free Basic target is to
take to Create Jobs were of God of
Future of Jobs and one for this of
course the investment for next in which
your investment Once but Of course I lot
and on
O Julian  present today
Hi friend is sad knowing there percent of
your house and home Fitness and
that sixty percent a ball comes up
Sporting CP and Training in every Year
your Windows they could Swim It Up with
the trade union  s the beginning organizations
and civil society but of course also the
infrastructure by the radio Station
goat Mundial by the member state front
father corrects uniforms in Franco your
Billing Solutions and the at target you
using The Number of people with of the
beatles Fifty Million including at least
five Million Children the Nobody has to
get rain in the euroforte the anthem of the mind
Pillars ren subjob for the semic Should I
still don't have a good education have
access to Shout Axl Rose and there is at
Hand Mirim
the taxol candles bring show and take  Hold of
your time you need to get Hold of Robert
vi só thank you very mate can always
this person the site adhere to these about
the bridge Model of the Portuguese
presidency
Ethen
Hi gracia rubber
é gratis e the cousin the minister Costa who
was Antônio  Grassi Ursula in Greece is
all the same or what year I
successfully organized appointment is tutte le parti
chucha clean editoriale what year
Laboratorial why Porto remains
in this one province
a small one calls the anthem that the door or
permanent Nereu in the promise that is with
him that there in the courses the year le nostre
istituzioni of our phones and
politician he transforms us his shawl
unheard of when he was with the pandemic filling
the penis that's not it  be in indirect March
the and students you love fight the door
oppermann Tenere with this ad
hi hey tested Gabriel my son killed di
e limpinho his press minister Costa
his the Portuguese presidency is
calm dirime will have center of European
Union with the policy and sociale
why  I move Northwest indirect
Hi Cristiane reason the route is to Porto
Hi Débora in favor is tutte le
institutioni e group e politiche di
European Parliament and not be a voter
Take Charlie Syndicate his brother
price me because otherwise he can and we abbiamo la
possibilità di sviluppare his policy
concrete that  the last one in our sad
tadinha super area with that tone
conscious moment cool painful include the
loss of dating é  a Lurde no
jorno
And it includes and diritti delle persone can
become direct
and Eliabe audio is a great journey
through the European union appetizer padme
And then naturally already left
Tutti there institutione to our for
collaborazioni Mack alla Nostra
discussione put in his field trigger
with credit credit that thing that I
take away the spirit some coconut this love
doesn't have you at the door I include Antônio arrive
invitato pull over note all to see
important
I stayed transitioner ecological
transitioner environmental and digital but
certainly in his life and press the
center he he his life  and press
that the Friar just for you you Alejandro de
la will not intend to understand our
free prioritá 1
we now have the time for some
questions and answers the first
question in room Rita siza
and her to Rita Silva Ltda portuguese from there
public Madam President a Object  from
time to Enjoy My Home Town but don't you
be joining the rest Of His original Ford
page on a  first aid and his ideas or
suggestions By The American president of
and temperei were of its whims a probe and
stayed from Letras no Word of
considerations are Gone Beyond Your
concern about the possibility of
technology transfers to Place his Sword
in and Prime Minister referred
now the measurement of the commitment that you have
just signed I would like to ask
if it would not be more ambitious instead of
having quantitative goals to have
binding goals thank you very much
question or
with Special needs to be a true friends
we've worked Because We need waxwings
now for the road and the short and
medium term Diaries waver Blocks old
problems Will not bring out of vaccine
left even of media in general São What is
necessary and  should turn me on Football
waxing and Share In Second Life is for
of vaccines diab free wi-fi and turn his
investments and increasing the capacity
to m  anufacture of vaccines And very
Clean and I hope Yours has started to
the vaccines series making some food for
example is now Being able to deliver
Seixal
and tals So if you studied this mouth anda
Way full Now also the vaccine charme with
exams be establish the food stamp  out
on a second helping the Export of the
Union is the only continent survision
democratic relations of this World Is
Sporting a pilot-scale where Fifty
percent of What is Being from the US and
Europe exported to almost nine countries
including cards to Run in Windows is  so
far there Have been in Export and Hold
about How hard you hit Me Once I Have
been delivered to the European people
and it also engaged and page of waiver
fee is how such Joy and is to come
é que se puede em lote share  of
What is beautiful girls and I we don't
wanna touch your Point indie told me the
washing investment capacity is not only
for example iupi helmets or loose work
you form that he wears M helmet if it
is  example an African capacity over
time on
Andthen it
's good I think one of the great one of the
good effects of this week was because
you allowed me to turn home and I'm very
pleased to have home I wanted to
say about the question put first
the fact of this plan of  action do not
write only actions but set meters of
targets for results to be achieved is very
important because it does not limit itself to saying
Let's increase employability I did not set
a target 38 percent of the
adult population employed in 2030 does not limit itself to
saying Let's increase training says
sixty  percent of the population must have
at least once
a year must attend Training actions not
just say let's reduce poverty say
let's reduce 15 million people who
are Open who are in a situation of
poverty five million of Parents are
children yours  place are goals that are more
demanding today than they were last year
because these goals have priority 2019 it
's important we don't just have to
r  to reduce in relation to 2019 we have to
reduce in relation to 2019 taking into
account everything that has worsened in terms of
poverty, namely in 2020 2021 with
the crisis of invitation there are two is a
much more demanding goal finally
serving collective good today
social opinion everyone made a commitment to
to carry out this action plan they
committed themselves to these goals and With
these results tomorrow at the end of the
Council we will have a
press conference to learn about the decisions of the
Council and see what is the commitment that
the council assumes regarding the goals
proposed by the commission now  I think
we cannot devalue these goals,
on the contrary, it was a huge step that the
commission took these very
precious goals on a European scale
and the next question for Pascal years to come
is
Zap or wi-fi Hello Passion and formations of
means making Friends etc  and if the game and
find me beautiful than good in size
with antiviral posesión de la revisión do
su chei  ro was good that your opinion
a dozen Because there is one and
mainly or ideal duration of Dori
Y se and discover that this horn p****
investment in very irresistible by
Valdir Simão means your lies would ask
you to meet you open [ __ ] Pit  Bull Air
Race of these one that only one of all
is a bad one she met Roberto that
they go to my saw of the day Kombi a owes a
lot to grow if they the people I
like
the excess thank you a am and measure of
be help  script correctly Have been
Hidden because from the same reason
aside I hold still coverplan Next
Generation you Beatles if we are one as
you open your contact by the member
state house in Seven hundred Fifty
billion Euro and capital Market but I
have to pay back one day  was then I Fall
How important that is Being expressed in
the best and future-proof players of
European Union that mitigates the risks
truck wheel Next Generation and who's
the Perspective Of The Next Generation
and da Lumen Christi esp  irrar and the
Crisis of the epidemic in
vou catch Lumen overwatch free streaming
and challenge The awful Truth
seventorrents End of the Earth is going
to add your Kingdom but Will not be able
to afford ample be successful in your
Penguin and You'll Be successful In  The
Field of the station and their Perfect
Person digital think and so self
cleaning out To You What You heard your
life Now is the best flat question in
Place also of God and Shake a those were
predicted Chelsea son of targets of
Miles Stones of hosting An  estimate of
the left and is Rich in little Kiss so
sweet bleeding so that you can monitor
or defend tip
a date this Lie behind the steps away
from Silva spider man state in Order to
get to the next one of which is Being at
first i
eb1
the fourth book A Arte Bial las
cuestiones em potes Romanesque building
is the first question for the three
presidents to know if after what they
saw from the social partners
during the afternoon of today it maintains  the
historic adjective for the commitment
that was reached in the city of Porto
and secondly, if from that
conversation you share
President Macron's opinion that the
recovery and resilience fund is no longer
enough to overcome the crisis and
that more is needed  money to
recover the European economy thanks
G1
I wasn't going to open love to think everything I
've read kunifas gothenburg power Union
right to put in the field DNS uniper improve and
limited in our sad ok Diniz
above all obeyed withhold and press f12
his is the hand in expectation a lot  time
and he must have with that ok eyes and he started to
measure is that it is a historic journey
from the European Union to the country the CONIC has
already been abolished since he took it off Thick
shawl is essential
from the game Alliance
protection and he presses that The Bone
the synonym of coming I operated in the policy
that I am testing or with this
policy here is the DG havi  the more together
I felt there Faro
and is that I stayed it is a
very important journey
Oi Edite da fact that today we also
support organization the civil society
Where and your Website and stakeholders
Dark Side DC Comics and is one of The
Strong Experience for the comment
section for legendary example hortons I
always end up leaving Motel only you can
never really get an idea of ​​the Upside
Down Upside Gold tuksen Major Elite
hero ambitious but stable and this
strong commitment of How this Wide Turn
on and at second question
hide-and-seek
o  Next Generation in your right now is
love and the Marshall plan am and this
animal uma investment and Europe with
comes when I Step Step at a bidding of
the Places we never would have Made to
have a place to show an experiment One
Direction you how to  keep people and
from you and he is now even Launcher
Next Generation you and me and so
on first blow Now make up and tell
her that is The National recovery plan
have to  be happy with How his worst
decisions have to be with The National
parliaments and I will said than We can not
be able to the Market to Raise money so
I have to be right now that we are able to
deliver and at for me the most important
step Lao  all
And why is it
historic why this time the social partners
are not signed how to participate in the
drafting for several months we
work together the presidency
the european parliament the commission the
social partners to draw up this
commitment together
and in gothenburg in 2017 a signature
between the institutions between the commission
and the european parliament but the
social partners never signed there had never been such
an agreement open people so ambitious
makes a truly tripartite agreement
on a european scale with all the
social partners sign the european union of
trade unions the three associations
representing employers  and the
civil city platform the chairman
of the commission the president parliament  the
european had never happened happened
historic i just wish that there are
even more historic moments than this one in the
future at this moment the great priority
is for our economic recovery EA
on the one hand that the states complete the
approval of the rectifications
AND since they allow the commission to increase
their own resources that have to go
to the market Practically all
have already approved very few yet to
prove next week there will be a
very important rotation for example in
the Finnish Parliament and therefore This is the
probability their priority is the state
of continuing to complete their
own national plans and
present them to the commission So
far only 14 states have
presented their recovery and
resilience plans to the european commission and the
great effort that i know the service
EA commission are making so that
we can obtain theirs
this approval is known as soon as possible What
is our ambition I have already said several times  es
publicly and we will work to make
it possible even during the
Portuguese presidency we can approve
a first package of plans and
the definition is also doing its
best let's see if we can achieve
that result let's concentrate on that and in
that expression begin to open the
operations plan itself  he eagerness had a
first part of seventy percent
definitely a bit based on the
results of the break in the
gross domestic product in mid-2020 and missed
a review in 2022 depending on the
final GDP 2020/2021 for final allocation of the
thirty percent that has  to be
balanced between the different countries
taking into account the effective impact of the
crisis we are still in a
relatively uncertain moment about the
final impact of the crisis we know that the
vaccination plan is going well we know that
in some economic sectors they are already in a
phase of taking  takes it up again
Good evening unfortunately you are still
in a very difficult situation seduction
is also  destiny from country to country and
function of its own
economic structure important this is the time as it
is the motto of our presidency it is the time
to fulfill and fulfilling means approving
the decisions that the national plans themselves and the arm
approve the national plans
for the plans
booming nationals That's what to end up doing is
what we see concentrating on doing
Maxwell political Trey Songz rubber band ring
french from results of the
first One and film features an example
if the commission With Brazil from that
which is now at the  books the member
States to know
the juror does surprise for Windows of
shows da take me to your Leader of Hair
and home of Salt water Power Supply
Ministro Costa websites which member
States simple one about at first Love
Ends turbine and present so it is what
rock  with benefits with files your
speakers Will see you just wanna take a
[Music]
look impactto or if another instrument
complete in new one very proud the
first one that vo  you found shock instrument
this time I'll see you say
Anymore when we finally got so much
should agree with this one I think is a
second half of the Year at three four
five minutes to get this one is even
bigger and It will be much  as Possible
member States to Get Ready With Me on
and you won't have to stay we expect to
member States at best to be done with it
and of Me and I tell you this was
because it depends on the ones Where the
lost ones with us in  the City which was
studied in Rats with Light leaks member
States We Can Only go to the Market the
next movie so if member States with on
the second of your microwave outro ta
Market on the first Day of your life
with the last of fans  and Friends with
modified Sweet Summer break and the
possibility to Raise money on the Market
is condition before we are
Dying  watch
the Master  r and Fashion in the displacement
of the uploading are so necessary in
and I would like that the state today we have
made a big appeal to
the member states in the sense of accelerating the
application process the overwhelming majority have
already rectified the caraka three that are
able to stay three or  four that still haven't
ratified
the barbecue with grande 145
member states to go replicate his already
scheduled is his rectification
Augusto increase wait for the replication
the others to feel more
accompanied in the rectification in the
final rectification process 30 I think we
have between the  in the final stretch this
weekend I will also have the opportunity to
speak personally with some of my
colleagues to see if it is possible to guarantee
without any doubt the fulfillment of
this calendar which is a
decisive calendar Because during the
summer months the markets are closed and it
belongs  here a delay and it means that
not behind the month is a hug can
take us out for the fall and that I  I believe that
we are all aware of the seriousness of
the economic and social crisis in Europe and
therefore we believe that it is necessary to
accelerate and not
in any way delay the execution of
this plan that is decisive
for the whole of Europe
portalcomuna vaccination we will all be for
each  one of us will be protected when
everyone is protected also from
an economic point of view the recovery will only
really start in each country
when it starts in all countries because
that's how the internal market works
who is
15 is the crisis getting so much electronic
The pee of the  for Biel to improve and I give this
love you will already see his hand here to
get
the baby's pee from the biome change
and that Guardian over there wait to restart from
Christ year it's a lot that you have been a lot to
create
a program to invent here the King without
link
I slept love increase its
protective capacity press baby bri
the sound of the piano increase it our
empower sulla Industrial policy of the
biome and  work and submit itally from the
biome to elaborate and common policy of
increasing and gradual solidarity in
which this year they are on Sat Telecom if
extraordinary and it
is because it did not lack right there
President Vanderlei a and and by a
local minister city wake him
experience of luxury Lust a
instrument of social policy that Viana
finances I am with Bonde Européia and
as a common habit Maceió came
directly his cousin collide that called the
break so putting in cm debt and
now for the price for the sailor
to invest in Cristiano south zone his
extraordinary business is
not me  swallow loves to continue on it Costa
extraordinary is area Johnny there
President to print Minister Ari who
loves and governs and parlament that Anchor
not there in fact to rectify to read shorts
I don't know a delicious minute of your own
that arrive of feeling to advance that in
active market and have the  see this in the
process having him European Union
iPhone from the burning And will have Abram in the
great success
Oh and you ti  see there I haven't done where o in
rabbit and shorts and per aiutare Haiti
tadini in price
I don't know rubbish ok it's not the Bible
and the blonde no and believe me that they open
right in which this is the moment to speed up the
oi oi
is the  my mobizone to operate the money would
add and to walk in which other
instrument and that to give up entered the
field with a very important and
very useful question to post on how to feel
God takes him out of this crisis and
how 27 countries and that the strong
Hello gang send Euro per questi sleep
of them feed how is it waiting for you
I saw the darling that in and we can't
chirida invites with irregular and dipress
the Hare at his feet is he already costs in the
good night
the map the tremor introduces in the fan as it
was  in his cousin covide the law I
dear that if Benny opens a big one
of
Basto we're already stupid it
's because rabbit and regulate what year the
product so much says that the alliance and
Cristiano fact confront her it gets Johnny
difficult he invites with his elegant mani
and this year they  and the journey if
year to be vice of le nostre comunica and
services where he our train price
Hi dear I met one fan in
this or that city invitation is that
we don't need to rest it's not to be
breastfeeding in one aspect
is  because you're with this it will depend on how much on the
island we will be one this skin
oh baby you baby I by Giovanni Dalle
donne and weight of seals you
what to give up color love you like the
series Thank you all good night free
Andthen
I  was helping the photo
What up
[Music]